Elon Musk files his lawsuit against
Media Matters an organization that seeks
to Simply lie about and Destroy people's
private businesses because they disagree
politically and then truth social filed
a lawsuit against 20 different media
outlets for a coordinated defamation
scheme where all of these Outlets
falsely claimed that truth social lost
$73 million now the crazy thing is
apparently they're all citing an SEC
filing that never says this so it's
going to get really really interesting
but here's where it gets interesting
even more so this morning when I wake up
and I said okay let's take a look at
where we're at with this Elon Musk story
there's a new story it's weird it's
actually an old story from about a month
and a half ago about a man who is suing
Elon Musk a Jewish man strangely when
you Google search Elon Musk now the news
you get is not that he's suing Media
Matters it is not the story explaining
how X and Elon Musk claim Media Matters
defrauded people it's actually a story
uh from a month and a half ago about
Elon mus being sued by a Jewish man for
being anti-Semitic